c'est à la pépinière au jardin de noiset
que les bitumeurs ont sévi il y a 2
semaines ils sont venus démarcher
directement sur place avec un discours
bien rodé ils sont venus un matin nous
démarcher en nous proposant qu'ils
avaient un relicat de goudron pour faire
des routes et en l'occurrence donc il
nous avaient dit qu'ils allaient refaire
la route de A à Z hein c'estàd avec un
dénivelé enfin et cetera et puis avec un
prix dérisoire enfin on va dire moitié
quoi donc on leur a dit pourquoi pas
fallait voir ensuite on n'a pas eu une
nouvelle pendant plusieurs jours ils
sont arrivés un matin avec les camions
et cetera et hop c'était parti des prix
défiants toute concurrence mais pas de
devis ils avaient estimer ça à 200 m²
pour si j'ai mémoire 10 €
euh le mètre carré si j'ai mémoire ça va
être comme ça doit être quelque chose
comme ça et au final est-ce que c'est ça
qui ah non pas du tout au final puisque
le le chemin fait pas 800 m mais avec la
largeur au global on en a pour 800 m
donc de voyez 2000 € c'est monté à 8000
€. voilà et avec un travail inachevé
puisque vous avez des trous euh partout
une facture plus élevée que prévue pour
un travail baclé les bitumeurs se
contentent de passer un rouleau
compresseur puis de couler goudron et
gravillon il ne leur aura fallu qu'une
heure pour faire les 800 m² des
individus bien connus de la gendarmerie
puisqu'ils effectuent ce type d'arnaque
presque chaque année à la même période
ce sont des des personnes appartenant à
la communauté des gens du voyage et
originaire d'Irlande ou d'Angleterre qui
viennent proposer leurs services pour
bitumer des des cours des allées chez
des particuliers des exploitations
agricoles ou des
entreprises sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et en particulier autour du
département d'indrloire et sur le
département d'indrloire ils viennent
souvent à une dizaine et se montrent
parfois agressif la gendarmerie appelle
donc à la plus grande vigilance face à
ses offres trop alléchantes